damn all right let's pause this and
we'll take this challenge
sue kara 14 47.
good luck we are black
e4 will play e5
knight f3 play knight c6
and we have a ponziania a ponziani
opening
all right you have not seen
the refutation
or maybe you have we'll see what he
plays
d3 or d4 both moves here d4 much more
common
and we'll go into this line knight takes
e4
see what you've got sukera playing d5
and this is the rukovic
gamut not playing knight e7 or knight b8
all right yeah um yeah this is the this
is called the vukovic
gambit it's probably the best way of
countering the ponziani in my opinion
foxy fury foxes fox's fury what's up man
how are you doing uh yeah vukovic game
sacrificing a piece
but my opponent does not take it we'll
take this bishop
bishop takes e3 and let's see
now my knight is attacked so i think
i'll move it to e7
and we'll see where my opponent plays
next he does have this pawn he can take
on
e5 there are some other moves available
as well
but we'll see what he goes for
okay he does take the pawn on e5 and i
think that is a good move
wouldn't want to play d6 here because
queen a4 check that's a fork on the uh
the king and the knight just learned man
trying to learn a lot more openings so
far my favorite is the
sewing sicilian definitely a very good
option
i think we're just going to castle here
so that we can play d6 maybe later
get out of this queen a4 tactic
we'll see what my opponent does next
his king's a little exposed maybe
looking to get castled
bishop d3 very expected yeah you know
developing this bishop
hitting the knight preparing to get
castled aiming the bishop at the queen
at the king side but here i think i've
got this move knight takes d5
and hanging this knight but
counter-attacking a pawn
so i would get two pawns for the piece
this pawn on d5 and this pawn on e3 all
right so
i'm not actually going for this pawn
that was not the idea i'm gonna play
this
queen h4 move instead forking the
king and the bishop now and that's gonna
how i'm gonna regain my peace i'll be up
a pawn
white's king will be very exposed thanks
for there has helped a lot no problem
man
it's uh my pleasure my pleasure yeah so
we're regaining this piece here
now we're forking this knight this pawn
and this rook
i actually just had this exact position
in a game yesterday
so um
so i'm actually very familiar with this
position this is still opening prep for
me
um and yeah knight f3 saving both the
knight and the rook but now there's this
knight takes e3 move threatening the
queen and also threatening
knight c2 which would be double check
and forking the king and the rook
hey arcg3 it's a pleasant surprise it's
me that is me
what's up dude how are you doing
yeah i uh i'm i'm i'm streaming for the
saint louis chess club now
does that does this mean that st louis
chess club
will allow anyone to stream on their
channel
i think maybe that's what that maybe
what
that's what this means i don't think i'm
too
too good of a streamer content creator
or chess player but maybe
maybe
jonathan sees potential on me so we
could take this queen of course or we
could go for
this knight c2 double check
i think knight
bd2 counter attacking the queen would
have been a much better try but
we'll just take this queen for now take
this queen
and it's also discovered check so
yeah very tricky position for white very
tricky
take the queen yep and now we'll take
this knight take this knight
and now what to do what to do
let's let's play d6 look to get another
piece into the mix
bishop f5 coming soon
and then the king can't return to the
back rank because the h1 rook hangs
yep yep yep yep all right let's see okay
we'll
continue with this bishop f5 check
bishop f5
all right and
king to b3 what to continue with
now queen d5 there's
c4 queen d3 check
if not then
[Music]
all right we'll play this move
not exactly yeah just saving the queen
looking for some you know
queen c2 or queen b5 moves obviously not
right now the
the knight guards both of those squares
but maybe look for some a5
a4 push get this rook into the game and
the king will be checkmated soon this
bishop doesn't hang because
queenie six is a fork mean machine
rex
what's up dude how are you doing
bishop hanging yeah bishop hanging that
would be a fork queen
e6 is a fork
mean machine rex yeah i don't know man i
i uh i recall you you were actually
following
you were following me in
uh in december or something in december
yeah i don't know how you got unfollowed
i don't know how you got unfollowed
and also um yeah i do have a personal
twitch channel so let me just
i'll type that in right now
there we go so if you enjoy the stream
today enjoy this segment go check it out
drop a follow
i do a lot of things there
try to keep my stuff entertaining give
you follow there as well thank you man
my opponent a bit of a think here okay
so i won't play c4 i think we'll just
continue this plane of a5
queen e6 no longer an option but there's
queen d3 now
now the pawn is moved off of c3
and where's the checkmate here where is
it
start with queen i uh
hmm
start with a4 a4 check
and now we'll go queen takes b2 that's
checkmate
push the pawn yes all right
good game sukara good game sukera